[Music]
hello everybody welcome to viewers
Choice thank you for coming first of all
I would like to introduce myself so my
name is Peppa cuenca the current chess
grandmaster here in st. Louis
and it's a pleasure to be here with all
of you and what are we doing here today
well we are going to analyze some games
from the YouTube channel users and I
would like to invite you to participate
during the class will be much more fun
so please you have any questions
comments etc etc so please don't
hesitate to ask
same for the YouTube people I see there
are some people already joining the
class so please ask whatever you want to
ask about the positions etc yeah so I
brought some interesting games today to
analyze the first one correspond to a
game played in Greece in the real Greece
championship under-16 between three on
Tefila DS me hail versus Carosa still
the rockies yeah her surnames
but interesting game alright so let's
start with it so why play it
efore c5 93 d6 here there are several
options available for whites so you
could go Bishop b5 one of the most solid
approaches right against the night off
or the open Sicilian d4 so see
tech-support Knight takes d4 Knight f6
Knight c3 and a6
you guys know how this different defense
is called
what kind of Sicilian do we have here
the night of year okay so this is
neither of one of the most aggressive
openings you can play with the black
pieces and yes also moreover you can
play here something like g6 this is the
dragon one of the most aggressive lines
also for black or you can play knight c6
the classical Sicilian right so there
are a lot of different approaches here
for black and here after a six again
there are several alternatives for white
here so for example Bishop g5 88 is a
move that I really like Bishop e2 and I
seen the guy in happen f3 going for the
English attack right so basically
White's idea is just to go to Bishop e3
Queen d2 long castle and then start
attacking on the key inside like g4 h 4
and later g5 right here black base e 5
you could say that this is not a very
good move maybe because now d5 it's a
wake square but the thing is you're
kicking this Knight from deeper and then
you're winning some Tempe right
okay so Knight B 3 they may move from
Bishop e6 this bishop comes here hit to
e6 to fight for d5 square right so in
many lines black will try to go d5 right
and here blacks come to plays based on
the open sea file right so as we were
saying this skin is going to go probably
to c1 after some long castling and then
rukon c8 will be perfectly placed right
blacks also trying to go something like
b5 and try it will try to start
attacking on the Queen side so Bishop e3
and now what do you what do you guys
think about the move d5 here in this
position it's a good move is it a bad
move people from YouTube as well looks
natural right or not
you think it's possible to go for it
okay yeah the point is after d5 you can
take everything it takes a finite xe5
90/65 and if you take with the bishop
what's the best move here for white
so what will you play here with the
white pieces any suggestions there 8 4
maybe key enough to know right
so c4 is the key
and when this Bishop goes back to e6 you
can just capture exactly chance this he
said c4 and now black cannot castle
after King d8 there's there's a lot of
trouble for black here in this position
right so you're gonna go roopd one or
even long castle in and then so night c5
or something and you're even gonna get
the bishop at this point right so that's
why I defy it's not a really good move
same happens if black takes with the
Queen Queen takes d5 you take on d5
Bishop takes on d5 long castles which
would be 6 and now 95 or even Knight a5
attacking this pawn on b7 and blacks
position is not very good so that's why
nobody plays here d5 even though it
looks like a very reasonable move right
but everybody instead place here which
will be is 7 do you want to go short
castle here in this position and then
develop your pieces so white went Queen
d2 here in this position very natural
move a me to go along castle in here and
this you want to start your attack on
there on the key inside right short
Castle long castle and night bd7
this night is better place on d7 done c8
why because c4 is a really interesting
in square and later you want to go b5
here in this position and this night can
join the party by a b6 where you are
aiming to go to c4 right c4 is a really
interesting to square for the knight
since from here you're attacking the
Queen and the bishop right so how do you
start attacking on the King side for for
white g3 you want to go g3 here for
Lando what would you play here with the
white pieces how do you start attacking
on the key inside
if you need to move the pawns exactly
you need to move the pawns so a natural
move will be exactly eight four would be
a really natural move and the other one
g4 yeah g4 is pretty natural you want to
go g5 keeping snagged back from f6 and
then you gain more control on the way
secure squared d5 right so that's why g4
is maybe the best move in this position
and black went here b5 alright so a
pretty natural move as I told you there
are some V force coming also Knight b6
intend to go night c4 and here white
plate rook e1 it's not a move the main
movies g5 by decade group g1 supports
the Jeep on whenever you go g5 letters
so rook e1 makes some sense right Knight
b6 was played here and now it's really
important moment because blacks
threatening to jam on c4 so how would
you stop that what would you play here
with the black pieces or maybe you wanna
continue attacking on the key inside
let's say g5 9 H 5 and H 4 so how do you
continue here with the black pieces
any suggestions any candidate moves
Knight c4 it's the most natural move you
attack the Queen and the bishop on your
forcing why to give the bishop pair I
never want to lose this bishop because
if you move the Queen like to f2 or
something then black and capture on e3
can capture on e3 and did like the dice
squares sorry the dark squares are
extremely weak for white so you have
this beautiful square an effort to jump
with your knife now remember der so
that's why maybe you have to take on c4
but now black is a really good move here
in this position you take with the
bishop or you take with the pond
so people from YouTube you can also say
something you take with the b-pawn you
take with the bishop exactly taking with
the pawn is the best option
since this Knight has to go to a one
right it's a really ugly square
Knight to a one in the corner punished
night and now you're going to attack a
lot on the B file rook b8 Queen a5
something like this this Knight is
joining the party by F force well so B
takes c4 and black is much better you
also got the bishop / so and the knight
on a 1 is basically doing nothing so I
would take with the pawn as well but
there is a really good move here in in
this position after Knight b6 it's a
very typical move in these positions how
do you stop Knight c4
exactly nine five best move in the
positions by far so you control c4 and
then you're also threatening to jump to
say six right so for example it black
plays something like nag c4 you can even
take on c4 b takes c4 g5 9 85 and 95 and
this point on c4 is hanging you're also
threatened to take on e7 followed by
Queen d6 there are too many threats you
take on d5 now the light squares are
extremely weak for for black the c4 pawn
is gonna fall sooner or later and white
is just better in this position so
that's why black didn't go for nag c4 in
this position but instead he tried to
cover the c6 square because if you do
something stupid like let's say rook e8
then 96 comes followed by 90 x e7 and
Queen d6 so you also have to parry that
trade how you pirate that threat by
playing Queen c7 that's a really natural
move right so 96 not possible anymore
and here white went G v g5 it's a really
natural move so this Knight is not going
to control g5 anymore has to go probably
to h5 as it went in the game I'm here
the best move in the position was Knight
to d5 but white player went king to be
one and now there's a really good move
for black in this position you always
have to take in account the unprotected
pieces so the knight 185 is more or less
unprotected so there was a really good
reaction here for black in this position
it's not an easy move but best move is
d5 here in this position crazy because
after exc 590 XE v 9t xe5 bishop takes
and now let's say Quinn takes the knight
on a 5 was hanging so and also the rook
on the one is unprotected so after rook
88 basically you have nowhere to go and
why this losing right you cannot protect
the rook on D 1 right so that's why the
5 was a really good more maybe black can
take on d5 and then play something like
Queen f2 so after Knight f4 position is
very a very unclear right you could take
on a5 but then the bishop on d5 is also
hanging maybe black is a little bit
better but nothing special right but
okay what went Kim b1 and now rook a c8
a really natural move here so putting
pressure on the C file and now what do
you play here with the white pieces this
night has come to 85 so now you can jump
to d5 and this is what white player did
here so Knight d5 the thing is whenever
black takes on d5 after 8 XD 5 you're
gonna have a really tasty square for
your night right the night from a5
whenever there is a pawn on d5 it could
go to c6 and block the C file right and
put some pressure on the e7 Bishop right
so basically black is forced to take on
d5 it takes d5 and Bishop f5 do you
think that Bishop d5 is a possible move
here
taking the video manic and the check in
see exactly so after Quint xt5 you could
think that blacks only movie screen see
to that the first month that comes to
our minds right but then a fake in situ
I think what can just go King a one and
nothing really happens here so you're
gonna develop your Bishop ID 3 then
there's no Queen c1 checkmate or
something
the bishop is protecting this important
squared so Queen c2 is not the move but
instead you can take 185 right but this
position it's really interesting because
white has sacrificed upon but we got the
bishop pair and after something like h4
position is really really interesting
you want to go see for some positions
you got good control on the c5 square
the bishop is going to come to d3 this
night it's actually doing basically it's
doing nothing on h5 whenever you go to
f4 we can just take it and then play h5
and increase the pressure because there
are some g6 nasty ideas right these
diagonals is extremely weak and it's not
easy for black to exchange heavy bases
right since c5 is control so this
position was very interested and very
unclear really but okay black went
Bishop f5 and now how will stop blacks
come into c2 so next is 6 now you plug
the C file the knight is perfectly
played place sorry on c6 now black has
to do something
I mean if black doesn't do anything
we're just gonna play Bishop d3 exchange
this light squares bishops after Queen
takes c3 we're gonna play some h4 and
then this Knight is stopping all blacks
contemplate right so that's why black
fell it had to open the position by
playing f6 here trying to open the f5
and now white went h4 kim h8 really not
so move so you want to be in front of
this rook on g1 right
and Bishop d3 takes takes
and black went F take C 5 H takes T 5
and now what do you think it's possible
to take on f3 what what swiped main main
threat in this position
so let's say black take some on a tree
what will you play here
lukkage once somebody same in the
YouTube channel okay look each one OK
ROCK each one makes a lot of sense right
because you can have a play metaphor
because of checkmate on a 7 right but
the thing is I think black can play here
j6 I'm more or less this game is safe
now
because there's no way of opening this
the H file right and the night on H 5 is
protected so instead of rook H 1 what
don't we play first exactly Thomas Healy
coolin he said g6 that's really good
move here in this position because
basically hi Black's first to play 8 6
so blacks never black never wants to
open the H filed right after H takes you
feel this is just suicide for black
right after something like Queen g6
then some rooks are coming to the H file
and G file so you got to close the
position after eight six but now Queen
e2 it's a really good move if the route
goes to f5 we play Queen to g4 and
basically there are too many threats and
you go to a tree what would you play
here white wins in two moves yes I
always talk about forcing moves
I insist a lot in this but just first of
all taking account captures checks and
threats so what can you capture here in
this position we can capture the beef
iPhone right this is pretty stupid right
but following this method you start
counting all the possible captures they
will we just say that this is just
nonsense right so then we can capture
the h5 night the eight six one who's who
says it exactly 97 Queen takes e7 and
now exactly what can you threat now in
this position so Oh
yeah so unprotected pieces we always
have to take them in account so queen g4
just threatens the two rooks and what
winds so pretty simple method right and
I guarantee you you're gonna solve a lot
of difficult puzzles this is what we do
in pastel paradise class we always
follow this forcing move method
okay so rocketry was not possible g6 was
played and now we need to a for Queen 83
was interesting but maybe too greedy in
order to go for the a6 124 is a move
that makes a lot of sense
do you centralize your queen you protect
your only weakness and now you want to
improve your pieces right okay so Rukh
f5 was played and now route d3 this rook
on d3 is well placed because you are
protecting f3 under ectly and also you
want to go route k3 at some point it's
half a block to do to protect the ACE
exponent maybe you want to go rue k-8 or
something but that's too passive - so
rooks c2 f8 putting pressure on F on f3
and now Bishop d2 simple move now you
protect f3 there are also Sun ideas
related by bringing this Bishop to a5 or
b4 and putting pressure on d6 later but
mainly you just want to protect f3 right
and now Knight f4 was played attacking
the rook rook a3 we are attacking the a6
pawn and here nitrate-free was played
looks extremely natural to me since we
attacking the rook or Knight on g1 and
also the pawn on d5 here maybe the best
move was 90 x e7 you're also taking this
rook quint x e7 rook g3 Knight f4 Andrew
k-6 and White's upon app but the white
player decided to go for a really
interesting valuation he played drew
cage one here allowing this fork
but the position gets really messy at
this point
so what's White's idea after native to
route 87 after keen 87 Queen h4 and
after King g8 yeah okay
this is the first idea that comes to our
minds so route 87 actually still the
only move right because if you move the
Queen like let's say it's a if you move
the Queen let's say Queen h4 then just
Knight h1 right and blacks an exchange
app and nothing to worry about so Luke 8
1787 Queen h4 k ng 8 but then if you
want to capture the knight on f2 then
Bishop g5 and again black is an exchange
up and I think position is perfectly
fine for black
so what's idea was much more interesting
so after rook 8 7 keen 87 Queen h4 King
g8 this very move for white here in this
position exactly
rue k-6 great move what's that red rue k
7 and it's really hard for black to stop
Luke a7 there was only one way to save
this position for black let's see if you
can find it Luke f7 this is what the
black black player played in the game
and this is losing because of ruke a7
crew k 7 and now what do you do
okay it's a little bit harder because
after Queen a 797 they struck eight
seven here Queen f2 ruk h1 Bishop c1
Bishop g5 what's gonna lose this piece
but after a three Roxie one teeny to
look at this point it's gonna fall and
white has too many passports so the game
continued kingi 790 xv5 Luke t1 and 90 x
e6 group d5 Queen a7 and this disc in is
also very weak and after some moves
black had to resign okay we got three
passports a safe King this point on g6
gonna fall as well black had to resign
but there was a brilliant move for black
in order to save the game let's see if
you guys can find it so rotate seven
Queen eight for King g8 bouquet six and
this is the key moment
rook b8 I didn't analyze this more for
let's let's do it all together here rook
b8 okay pretty interesting so now after
Luke a7 you just want to go group B
seven but that has a drawback that you
are not protecting the back trunk
anymore
so after Luke a7 only move rook d7 now
you can play
maybe Luke a8 check no because there is
rook f8 right so let's try to find the
solution here very interesting move rook
b8 so okay seven rook d7 rook e8 Brooke
f8 right nothing really happens I guess
at least you can take on b8 and then
take on f2 and white white should be
better in that position but there are
also moves like Queen eight six here
which are very very interesting we need
six how do you protect the g6 pawn
looks tasty
Kien f7 runs into queen eight seven
right and then this looks really really
dangerous
yeah it's gonna fall
so I guess queen is sick is very
interesting and also as I told you this
this line should be also should be very
good as well for white here we have two
this skin is now much safer place than
black skin all right
so rook b8 not the solution what's the
solution here after bouquet six king f7
Lucas do 84/100 is saying king f7 kina
seven runs into blue k7 again right so
no
rook 8 to f7 I think same problem rule
k7 so the move is route kept three
because now what happens after ruh k7
can you find the solution here for black
actually I think blacks winning here yes
blacks win
yes when takes a seven-night xr7 and now
exactly ruk a tree back trunk problems
background problems okay so this Queen
has to go away let's say Queen before
and now Rock h1 Bishop c1 and now Bishop
g5 and this is the same line has
happened in the game but with a piece up
for black yeah okay
so this was the game and very
interesting sacrificed 187 and after
drew k-6
as I told you rook f7 was played Luke a7
and white won the game so I'm gonna show
you another game I have four games ready
for today's class so this is a much
simpler game let me just show you
hmm yes this is a game from the user
jakku f-- he was driving the white
pieces d4 Knight f6 c4 c6 Knight c3 two
main options here for black one of them
is the groom fault which is played in
the top level in a lot of games and the
other one is to play Bishop d7 in order
to go for which opening how do you call
this opening with with black Kings
Indian yeah one of my favorites I have
been playing the King Kingdom my whole
life it's really aggressive and you're
aiming to get a lot of double-edged
positions so Bishop g7 basically you
concede the centre for the white player
and then you wanna break break it by
some defy voor c5 so native three short
castle and here the main move goes after
a four but instead in this game white
went Bishop g5 really natural move
developing your minor pieces so
basically you want to continue with III
Bishop b2 or Bishop d3 and ensure castle
so pretty natural move Bishop d5 d6 was
played enough six sorry III black played
you know there may be to develop the
cream by a five at some point B should
be to 9b d7 Queen c2 and eight six what
do you think about this eight six move
it's pretty natural right so Bishop
eight four and now I want to ask you
what do you think black should play here
in this position there are a lot of teas
and options here for black
sorry II five if I dust that's the most
natural move in the position what do you
think about trying to get the bishop
where how you get the bishop pair here
g5 and after Bishop G 395 you fell in
the same trip let's try to understand
what happened
so black player went g5 in order to get
the bishop pair Bishop g3 9 h5 now of
course you want to take on g3 and then
play something like e 5 black would be
in good shape
let's say after short Castle Knight xt3
H takes c3 and e5 something like this
you got the bishop pair you got nice
Center you want to continue maybe with
f5 Queen e7 and I would say black is
even better but tactical problems what
happens after Knight age 595 wins at
least upon the problem is normally there
is this intermediate move here but after
Knight 63 what do you think you take
with f1 or with h1 eight point because
now exactly
if this rook was only eight you could
take on g5 and then run away too afraid
right but the problem is now that after
age 65 Queen eggs have been made
sorry yeah that's even better yeah
that's even better
yeah 397 exactly this is too deep it's
Texas III yeah so Ned jeez 95 sorry and
in the game black realized about the
problem now and he had to take on g5h
takes e5 [ __ ] takes 85 this is only a
matter of time now but there are some
tricks that black player can post now so
if I was played long castle and now I
wanted to show you this line so in the
game Knight f6 was played but here I
wanted to show you this it takes e4 it
takes e4 and now there's a good move for
black here which creates a lot of mess
what's the best move for black here
come on YouTube guys
do you see it jeepers that's a very good
move because now white can take on g4
because of Queen g5 and you're actually
threatening Queen g5 so how do you stop
Queen g5 first move that comes to your
mind quick eight four great now boom
Knight f6 the bishop is trapped
so basically eight four losses so that's
why D for was creating some trouble but
here for example f4 and after Knight f6
Bishop h4 right with the pond own age
for this pink was not possible now it is
and white should be better
but okay in the game Jack oops opponent
plate 9 f6 here sorry II five long
Castle Knight f6 Bishop e2 and this
position is extremely good for white
you're gonna play h4 you're gonna open
the H file basically it's gonna be
checkmate in few moves Queen c7 also
there was some pressure on e5 8 4g for
trying to close that position 85 [ __ ]
wait six dissipate for attacking the
knight from f6 Knight 7 Bishop d3
attacking this Knight f5 de de c5 in
order to get this square for the bishop
and now after b5 was played white can't
win more material how do you weigh more
material all right let's say after CB AV
again four-seam oops captures checks and
threads can we check yes Queen B 3
that's an improve our possess improve
our position I don't know because of the
King h8 looks like nothing happens right
Bishop c4 that's your the possibility
King h8 those are the checks captures
Bishop f5 stupid move there are no more
captures right no threats
can we threat checkmate can we threat a
queen exactly you see this method it
works now I defy you you are threatening
the Queen
he can't take and then when the Queen
moves what do you play let's say Queen B
740 moves checks
97 and then captures c6 that's okay
that's risky that's risky yeah there's
this screen and keen on the C file you
want to open it maybe it works but it
looks extremely risky right but there's
another capture here 95 right and after
Bishop takes Bishop takes now root K 2
is not working because of what this is
an easy one yeah there are many moves
but there's one good move which wins on
the spot
I guess route d7 right right yeah okay
Quinn takes root K 1 yeah okay it's a
little bit more complicated but let's
say King D to rook H 1 and now Queen g6
right so it's winning it's winning so
yeah this was the game by Jacob so he
wanted to get the bishop er but there
were a lot of tactical problems with
this Knight g5 ooh sorry
so let's check another game for example
a Larson game so and we have a message
from the users hold it says hello Sal
Louise Chess Club I'm a frequent waiver
of your videos I recently played a fan
admin again that I hope you show I like
this game for a couple of reasons first
of all despite not being very clean it
is my highest rated win on the site also
I played f6 or moved 13 while telling
myself never play f6
because I could not see how it could be
punished nevertheless it as always was a
mistake and you could show why since my
opponent did not see it so we'll try to
to figure it out my favorite part is
that my move 26 is initially regarded as
a mistake by stockfish but after a
minute or so it finds that it is
actually the best move I'm playing back
I am about 1900 on the side and my
opponent was almost 2200 thanks all
right so let's check the game b3 the
Larson my favorite reply or answer
against me 3 is 'if I've okay B should
be 296 he 3 9 f6 Bishop b5 and Bishop d6
this is what I normally play against the
Larsson so blacks ad is just to kick
this Bishop from b5 normally white takes
on c6 you take back with the pond and
black is more or less okay but okay he
black goes d5 Bishop b2 and c5 grabbing
some space in the center it's pretty
natural III and Bishop f5
also good so when I go on ninety six is
six and the bishop is out of the shank
the pawn chain right 93 96 and now the
fight is normally centered on the e5
square so how do you eliminate a piece
from a Fife and also at the same time
you develop a piece Bishop where this
would be 5 right the most natural move
pin in this Knight also you gain more
control on the e5 square
Queen c7 sure Castle is 6 and here I
really like c4 c4 aiming to go for some
isolated pawn structure after Knight f6
c d e v and d4 and this is very very
comfortable for white but ok he decided
to go for d3 pretty natural move aiming
to go Knight bTW to
maybe later efore or even 95 followed by
f4 and then supporting this night from
f3 - hello
so d3 was played not f6 and Knight e5 so
as I told you plan is Knight B to d2 +
f4 Bishop d6 was played and effort the
only move right the only reasonable move
because you play something like knight
c6 you have lost in the fight for the e
Phi squared B Tech c6 you have to go to
a for something this looks pretty ugly
and now black has won the fight for the
e5 square so if you know but not to lose
that fight you play F for now black
played a six force in Y to capture in c6
right so Bishop takes c6 b takes c6 and
92 g4 was really interesting here G for
forcing black to go to g6 and now
something like let's say 92 or even
Queen e2 and you have a lot of space
here and a lot of threats so on f5
coming later not now because the knight
on e5 hangings on h4 a move coming as
well and this Bishop is indeed trouble
but okay white when 92 and now black
stops g4 by playing h5 pretty natural
Knight d2 F 3 again control of the e5
square so till now White has played a
very decent game Knight g4 what's blacks
idea would you take on g4
yeah looks risky right because yeah you
open the H file and then could be
dangerous right but okay blacks
threatenin III so you got to defend it
like Queen e2 or Queen e1 are the most
reasonable moves right white went Queen
e1 here and now are you sir he was
asking I wanted to play f6 but I was
telling to myself don't do it I think
it's a mistake but I don't see why can
you explain what can you explain this to
me
all right again this is a mess so here
white went Knight takes e4 h sexy 4 and
actually the H file is open black
started to get better in this position
but there is a brilliant move here for
white okay if you don't move the knight
you have to threaten something
what could you threat in this position
efore right if we're very good move
that's why f6 was not the right move to
play here and now I know there are like
five possible captures that this is a
mess that some sometimes we get too lazy
to calculate everything right happens to
me I don't know about you guys but
they're like ten possible captures just
want to go home but after a fourth we
have to calculate at least f2x e5 and
piece of eight seven right let's start
with F 2x e5 the point is I will just
take on f5 and it black takes on f4
which is kind of forced right it takes F
for what will you play here with white
yes you're a d right good to have you
back ready
so yeah exactly Queen takes c6 and at a
queen e7 what would you play here Adi
exactly because now
black can't play Queen f7 since the
bishop on d6 is Sangin so black has to
move the King let's say to f8 and this
position looks extremely ugly for for
for black right
so for example rue k e1 and then g5
there are too many threats OOP sorry
okay so f takes e5 doesn't work you
could take on f5 here but then F takes
e5 mission be 783 this nag has to go
back to 86 and for example now something
like knowledge for putting pressure on
f5 and then there are too many witnesses
here let's say sure Castle you can play
Knight g6 and then the root can't come
to f7 because of a six and you go to
create or something like that you can
play something like Queen e2 and then
attack the h5 phone right so this
doesn't look very good but the question
is what happens after Bishop 87 just now
it looks like we have to take on g4 but
there is another good option for white
here
Adie what do you think
black skin is on the center-right how do
we open files exactly
eat XD 5 is really good move cost now
first thing it black takes back we can
just now take on g4 and Queenie six the
bishop is not on f5 anymore is six is
not protected enough to the check we're
going to capture the g4 point white is
much better but what happens after F
takes e5 we can just take back bishop f8
only move because of the Bishop e7
there's this fork right with d6 I don't
know why in Spanish we call this kind of
after Bishop e7 sorry Bishop e7 in
Spanish for this kind of move with upon
that threatens with two pieces we call
it the underwear like Calvin feels
really strange and don't ask me why
yeah so Bishop f8 only move d6 and this
position is extremely good for white we
got two points for the piece we're going
to get a third one like something at the
bishop a3 and look at black pieces the
bishop f8 can move the knight we'll have
to go back to 86 the King better not to
castle a long long side because it's
extremely weak over there there are some
Queen a5 moves coming
so basically white is much much better
so the key move after f6 was in for but
it was a rapid gain of course and it's
not easy to spot that move
so instead why - kanji 4-h takes e4 and
now the H file is open so position is
starting to look good for black married
for was played and long castle for our
user and here next to X f5 I think this
was not necessary not yet right because
for example you can play something like
g3 and you want to keep this file closed
right maybe you want to start some sort
of counter play on the keen side but I
think taking on f5 is not very smart
since now blacks plan is too easy so
it's just trying to bring some pieces to
the edge file and then to put some
pressure here so NIDA 5 was played eat
xf 5 and G 3 blue k3 black is coming
we need to Luke h8 and we're getting to
an important moment rook F to Quinn f7
and here it's a really important moment
d4 I think this is a pretty natural move
so we have to start on sort of counter
play on the keen side sorry on the Queen
side right since again it looks very
weak here but our user played a really
tricky move Queen h5
where are you threatening here with
black pieces
exactly that's the threat how do you
stop that you want to take on a six or
you want to pray prophylactically
prophylaxis is really important so
before thinking in our own plans we have
to stop our opponents plan there is only
one good move here for white exactly
group T - that's the best move so
there's no more root G 3 and it looks
like these three pieces
they look nice there but everything is
well protected and now we are the ones
tacking on the queenside this was the
best move who was guaranteeing quite a
good position but instead he was too
greedy and he took the pawn on e6 we
checked an attack in d7 now he can't
face the two threats that black is
posing black is threatening to take on
g3 and also on h2 so there's no way of
stopping both so that's why white
started to give some checks queen b-17
is six no more checks he took on g7 and
now what do we play rogue g3 check
exactly Adam you can't take because
there's checkmate on the h1 square and
after keen f1 Queen a trade check King e
to give me another pawn kin D - and now
the brilliant move our users spotted in
the game he said that stock fish was not
recommending it how do you how do we
finish our opponent tab several moves
so the move was exactly Bishop f4 this
is how the game continued and after rook
effort Queen x2 and after King III roll
cage free checkmate
this is how the game finished so a
pretty interesting game the key moment
of the game was this f6 a layered white
had to play prophylactically with this
rookie tool and then everything could
have happened in that position all right
so last game before we move to the
Romantic era Plus for this game it's a
French it's a French yet this game hi
this is a game I played in a grated
League in England opening is the alkene
shot R and it is quite interesting and a
big fan of your channel keep the great
content coming
all right so if 4 is 6 this is the
French defense d4 d5 and Knight c3
different alternatives here for white
the terrace variation 92 you can also
play e5 right also this beautiful move
Bishop d3 it's more interesting than you
think and they exchange variations
boring right don't play that but ok
white play Knight c3 I'm here in the
game Knight f6 was played the classical
variation of the French do you know how
this variation is called after Bishop b4
B now where variation yeah one of the
most complicated openings is very
difficult to understand the structures
that arise after the V now were so black
plays c5 83 and then there are these
double points
so basically white is trying to give
check to checkmate otherwise it will
suffer on the Queen side so whenever I
take the white pieces I don't manage to
get to checkmate and then I lose and
then when I get the white piece at the
black pieces then they check
I never understand what's going on so
native six Bishop g5 the other
alternative is a five here Bishop t5
Bishop e7 p 597 and eight for these pawn
sacrifice is very interesting it's
called the chatter variation so
basically if black takes H takes Queen
takes now white gains some Tempe after
playing narrator e let's say queen is
seven and queen g4 and you're putting a
lot of pressure on the King side let's
say g6 Knight g5 85 and Queen f4 White
is going to go long castle in and there
are some g4 ideas and then there's a lot
of pressure that's why it's also
interesting not to take the pawn on d5
but instead playing eight six which now
is forcing y to take on e7 or to go back
to e3 or to f4 the most natural move is
Bishop fe7 Queen to X is 7 + f4 followed
by Knight f3 Queen d2 and long Castle
but here y decided to retreat the bishop
where would you retreat your Bishop to
e3 or to f4 yes Adi
yes yeah exactly
so very good so basically you want to
reinforce your pawn chain by f4 at some
point right so you go to f4 basically
after c5 you're not going to be able to
protect your pawn chain right so black
is destroying it so that's why Bishop e3
is the best move here or Bishop e7 but
be sure before I would say it's a little
bit dubious but this is what happened in
the game Bishop f4 Bishop b4 was check
boss was played what do you think about
this move
what are you supposed to do here with
but with the black pieces you have a
lack of space right so white house and I
spayed advantage so you have to break
that pond chain a dc5 that was a move c5
d 2x e 5 let's say knight c6 you don't
have to capture immediately you can put
pressure on the central pawn and after
Knight f3 for example something like
night c5 and I really like blacks
position here but okay Bishop before
already not the best move I would say
queen g4 attacking the g7 point Bishop
c3 check be take c3 and keen f8 and now
you can see that white positioning
starts to look very good so you want to
go native 3 Bishop d3 sure castle or
even h5 continue attacking on the key
inside right native three nights e6 was
played again not with the spirit of the
position you want to break on c5 at some
point Jace there are weaknesses here
that you can attack with your queen or
you can even try to exchange this poor
bishop right so the most problematic
piece for the black player in the French
is the light square bishop because it
doesn't enjoy proper diagonals so one
good idea is normally to try to exchange
it for this good Bishop which is
normally placed on d3 and with a lot of
attacking perspectives right so one nice
plan for black here is to play b6 and
Bishop a6 or to break on c5 but you play
96 again c5 it's not possible and then
yeah ok you want to go 97 and try to
protect your kin but still you're
wasting too much time
Bishop d3 was played 97 and c4 what do
you think about this move
I would say it's reasonable because you
got the bishop pair you want to open the
position right and black skin is not
able to castle so it's good to open
Lang's
c5 finally it comes c3 Queen a5 was
played attacking c3 how you protect it
Bishop d2 yeah that's very reasonable
Bishop d2 also there is this available
square for the Queen on f4 where you can
put some pressure on the f7 point I have
seen maneuvers like that like rook a
tree root D trees were on the French
very interesting or if there's not an
eye 23 this rook can join the party by
f3 attack in f7 which is one of the most
weakest squares for the black side right
so here Queen a6 was very interesting
since this Bishop is unprotected and
then you're gonna win this pawn let's
say a 4 takes and Bishop e2 still the
position remains extremely complicated
because this skin is not very well
placed
but Queenie sik was maybe the move all
right black played b5 here interesting
move she takes me 5 the point is he want
to recapture that point after playing c4
bishop c2 and Queen takes e5 but there
is a huge drawback for black now what's
now the quickest diagonal for black look
at this Bishop it's a very typical
maneuver in the French Adi
exactly that's really good
Adi so white plan many times hippo a for
Bishop see one Bishop a three and this
Bishop is so strong in this day ona so
long shot castle was played King g8 and
a for the Queen has to go back and look
Fe one of course also possible to go
Bishop c1 straightaway Abu have done
that probably but rook Fe one was played
narrow fate and I was checking this game
and I couldn't understand why why didn't
want to go h5 because 85 actually
stopped any blacks activity on the Kings
side right so there is no square
available for this night so h5 is
actually really good move and then you
can continue slowly progressing yeah you
can bring this Bishop to see one and A
three putting pressure on these two
nights then you can remove if you want
the night from the f3 in order to start
up on March on the key inside but h5 is
necessary actually in this position so
native to was played I don't know for
some reason he didn't wanna go h5 so 95
a 528 still the position is very very
good for for white here Queen 83 maybe
now I was possible for black to play h5
he wants to go g4 but okay Queen d8 9 f3
going there and here 96 g3 again h5 was
very good for some reason he wanted to
go g4 and g5 instead of h5 first so this
is a clear position on mistake g3
not F 8 g4 again h5 the best move by far
because after g5 what can you play now
with black to close the position
h5 right h5 and subtle is not that easy
to continue attacking on the key inside
even though if black plays something
really ugly like g6 now the king is more
or less safe you can bring the King
later to g7 and then these pieces can go
back to life and the bishop on c1 here
is talking nothing so that's why h5 is
necessary in this kind of position after
having played h v g5 is much more
stronger g5 905 they didn't play 8 v
either so now G takes h6 night x86 keen
h1 this looks extremely dangerous for
black though now because the G file is
open and not a 5 8 5 9 8 7 so here a
very interesting defensive idea was to
keep this night on f8 and after
something like let's say Knight g6
it's not that easy to proceed with the
white pieces now these rogue on h8 is
doing a fantastic job
the thing is after 9 8 7 group G 1 there
are many threats now Bishop d7 and Queen
to g4 and how do you stop white from
taking on f5 and on g7 you'll find any
solution how you stopped made into
running away right so King f8 yeah but
after Bishop takes Queen g7 yeah so
let's say King f8 this is just hopeless
right so takes takes Queen g7 so you
don't want to lose the rogue you have to
go to e7 and then boom Bishop e3 and
blacks losing so they played Queen f8
but now the killer move what's a killing
move here we said this bishop was going
to
somewhere else yeah exactly Bishop a3
deviation now he's got to go or I seen
the gang happened 97 and Bishop e7
and black had to reset all right so we
analyzed for gains from our users I hope
you liked the class now we're going to
check in the Romantic era where we will
talk about above Anderson one of my
favorite players thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]